most of these people are from Zimbabwe
they say they were attacked on Monday at
around 3:00 in the afternoon local time
they saw dozens of men heading towards
them telling them to leave South Africa
because they are foreigners what wasn't
littered was destroyed all of us we are
human beings so we have to if miss for
each other the way they are treated each
other is not even good with the f2f miss
because all of us were all Africans it's
only the difference because of their
borders but all of us we're all blacks
Africans soaring inflation rising food
prices and high unemployment in Zimbabwe
made it difficult to survive they that's
why they came here to look for work but
some locals feel foreigners from other
parts of Africa are competing with them
for scarce jobs and government services
more than 100 people have lost their
belongings during the violence they
trying to start over and rebuild their
homes but many say they still don't feel
safe here afraid African foreigners
could be targeted again president sarama
pasa has condemned the attacks as in a
phobic and unacceptable mainly foreign
owned businesses and African foreign
nationals have been attacked threats of
reprisals for South Africa to
temporarily shut his Embassy and
consulate in Nigeria with people have
been protesting against the attacks
they've also been demonstrations in
Zambia people they are threatening to
boycott South African companies like
Shop Rite supermarket no South African
business person shall brilliant product
in some jobs
if the ultimatum is not adhere to sharp
right shall be closed after days of
rioting and looting is now relatively
quiet em Pretoria and Johannesburg
people are assessing what was lost and
trying to pick up the pieces but it
could take longer for South Africa to
repair the damage done and change the
perception some have that foreign
African nationals are not welcome here
Hara Mutasa al-jazeera Victoria